und jetzt beginnt doch die Debatte über
die Lkw-Maut die erhöhte
ein Viertel aller Güter über die Schiene
transportiert werden das ist das Ziel
dass wir uns gesetzt haben und deshalb
sanieren wir jetzt die wichtigsten
schienenkorridore elektrifizieren und
digitalisieren Strecken und
Stellwerke wir fördern den kombinierten
Verkehr und können allein im kommenden
Jahr gut 9 Milliarden Euro in die
Schieneninfrastruktur investieren
tatsache ist aber auch der Großteil des
Güterverkehrs findet auf der Straße
statt manchen passt das manchen passt
das nicht aber es ist eine Tatsache mit
der wir umgehen müssen
es kann nun einmal nicht jeder Laden und
jedes Werk einen schienenanschluss haben
oder unmittelbar an einem Fluss liegen
LKW-Transporte sie sichern uns
Lieferketten versorgen Supermärkte und
Unternehmen sind bei wohnungsumzügen
unverzichtbar und werden gerade jetzt in
der beginnenden Weihnachtszeit Millionen
von Paketen dann ihr Ziel bringen wir
brauchen den LKW liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und deshalb müssen wir drei
Projekte anpacken wir müssen erstens den
antriebswechsel auf der Straße
voranbringen dafür haben wir diverse
Förderprojekte und unseren Masterplan
leider Infrastruktur 2 wir müssen
zweitens dafür sorgen dass unsere
Straßen in einem guten Zustand sind und
das Netz dort wo es nötig ist ausbauen
und die haben meine Damen und Herren wir
müssen das Netz auch an einigen
eckenpunkten ausbauen denn es gibt kaum
überflüssigere CO2-Emissionen als jene
von Lkw die im Stau stehen oder
kilometerlange Umleitungen fahren müssen
und drittens müssen wir um das System
fair zu gestalten diejenigen Nutzer die
unsere Straßen und Brücken am stärksten
belasten an den Kosten beteiligen und
genau das machen wir mit der Lkw-Maut
mit den krafttreten der
eurovignettenrichtlinie ist das seit
neuestem möglich bei der Berechnung der
Mautsätze auch die Kosten für die
Lärmbelastung und die Luftverschmutzung
stärker zu berücksichtigen
diese Bundesregierung hat sich
entschlossen davon Gebrauch zu machen
und das ist nur fair das Ergebnis dieser
mautanpassungen sind moderat steigende
Mautsätze die dazu beitragen die
Finanzierung unserer Infrastruktur auch
für die Zukunft zu sichern und das liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ist für eine
Gesellschaft die mobil sein möchte
essenziell
denn wie ich vorgestern bereits im
Rahmen meiner Rede zum Haushalt 2023
gesagt habe wie wichtig eine gute
Infrastruktur ist wissen wir immer dann
wenn sie nicht funktioniert dann Gerät
plötzlich alles ins Stocken eine marode
oder zu knappe Infrastruktur ist nichts
was ich mal eben reparieren lässt
Engpässe zu beseitigen Straßen zu
erweitern oder eine überlastete Brücke
zu ersetzen das dauert in der Regel
Jahre und das sehen wir derzeit
schmerzlich in Nordrhein-Westfalen
Lüdenscheid in der Rahmenbedingungen und
deshalb dürfen Investitionen in die
Infrastruktur nicht ausschließlich nach
Kassenlage erfolgen sie müssen mit
Weitsicht und einem langen Atem
verfolgen beides zeichnet eine
verantwortungsvolle Politik aus und
beides schulden wir auch den
nachfolgenden Generationen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit
diesem Gesetzentwurf gehen wir den einen
nicht weit genug und für andere geht er
zu weit aber genau das kennzeichnet
einen fairen Kompromiss und deshalb
bitte ich Sie um Zustimmung vielen Dank
Volker Wissing der
Bundesverkehrsminister mit Erläuterungen
zur höheren Maut ab 2023 drei Kriterien
hat er genannt andere Fahrzeuge müssen
auf die Straße mehr E-Mobilität aber
Straßen müssen auch gepflegt und
ausgebaut werden und die Nutzer müssen
mehr an den Kosten beteiligt werden und
dazu haben wir jetzt Martina Engel hat
Kopf aus der CSU Landesgruppe die
nebenbei auch noch Mitglied im Eisenbahn
infrastrukturbeirat der
Bundesnetzagentur ist liegt heute der
Gesetzesentwurf in der ursprünglich
eingebrachten Form vor wir von der Union
sind damit nicht einverstanden und
lehnen diesen ab wir legen zwei
Entschließungsanträge deshalb auch vor
in einer schwierigen wirtschaftlichen
Situation in der wir uns gegenwärtig
befinden und auch die Transport und
Logistikbranche stark unter Druck steht
halten wir es für ein völlig falsches
und verfehltes Zeichen hier weiter
Belastungen oben draufzusetzen die
Lkw-Maut zu erhöhen es gibt ein
Entlastungspaket nach dem anderen dass
sie von der ampelregierung auch auflegen
aber es ist nichts dabei für die
Transport und Logistikbranche ich möchte
an dieser Stelle kurz den drei monatigen
Tankrabatt auf skizzieren der ja als
Entlastung gedacht war aber sie alle
wissen was passiert ist er hat seine
Wirkung verfehlt die Milliarden schweren
Steuersubventionen wurden in Teilen
weitergegeben die Branche in Teilen
entlastet oder aber auch die Autofahrer
an dieser Stelle es wurde groß
angekündigt hier auch über das
Kartellamt einzugreifen das Kartellamt
mit Clown und Zähne auszustatten aber es
ist nichts passiert die Wirkung ist
verfehlt und die Milliarden sind auch
hängen geblieben bei Großhändlern bei
Mineralölkonzernen völlig verfehlt an
dieser Stelle aufgrund der gegenwärtig
immer noch sehr hohen Belastungen ist es
aus unserer Sicht deshalb notwendig den
rechts sicheren Teil auch weiterzugeben
ich spreche über die Infrastrukturkosten
als einen Teilsatz der Maut um auch
Rechtssicherheit auch herzustellen sie
planen ja bereits weitere Erhöhungen im
Bereich angekündigten
novellierungsschritt Nummer zweien
kommenden Jahr mit Luft und Lärm CO2
Bepreisung dass er alles mit eingepreist
werden soll und es wäre auch möglich
gewesen hier abzusenken an dieser Stelle
ein Zeichen an die Branche auch zu geben
und zu entlasten und wenn Sie jetzt hier
über Gegenfinanzierung vielleicht diese
die Frage auch aufwerfen sie haben so
viel Kreativität gezeigt im Bereich der
unterschiedlichsten entlastungspaketen
Hunderte von Milliarden
an Pakete an Schattenhaushalt auch
aufgebaut alles über schuldenfinanziert
und sie nennen das auch noch
Sondervermögen an dieser Stelle es wäre
auch hier möglich gewesen einen kleinen
Teil des Kuchens auch an eine
systemrelevante Branche wie die
Transport und Logistikbranche
weiterzugeben
ein weiterer wesentlicher Punkt ist der
zweite Entschließungsantrag es geht hier
um die mautbefreiung für
Hilfsgütertransporte ich denke an das
zerstört sie Aathal hier waren es
Ehrenamtler die Baumaterialien
transportiert haben der Katastrophenfall
war bereits aufgehoben und aufgrund
dessen kam hier noch die Maut oben drauf
lassen Sie uns heute hier gemeinsam eine
Gesetzeslücke schließen stimmen Sie hier
für unseren Entschließungsantrag um
ehrenamtlich Engagement bei uns im Land
bei höchstgitter Transporten auch von
der Maut zu befreien herzlichen Dank
Martina Engel hat Kopf war das aus der
Unionsfraktion der Bundestag diskutiert
über höhere gemautgebühren für LKW
abkommendem Jahr und dazu jetzt der
Vorsitzende des Verkehrsausschusses Udo
Schiffner aus der SPD-Fraktion
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
die einen Ende Streit ich nenne es eine
gute Diskussion
über den richtigen Weg also ich denke
man sollte nicht unterschiedliche
Auffassungen immer als Streit abtun
sondern als Beitrag auch hier in der
Auseinandersetzung unter Partner wenn
man den richtigen Weg finden will frau
Kollegin wir entwickeln die Lkw-Maut
weiter im ersten Schritt heute durch die
Änderung des Bundes Fernstraßen
mautgesetzes nach Maßgaben aus dem
letzten wegekostengutachten und wir
gehen diese Schritte weiter auch in den
kommenden Jahren
und gerade im nächsten Jahr wird es
darum gehen auch noch mal gravierende
Änderungen in diesem Bereich anzustoßen
und zu diskutieren und zu beschließen
ich möchte noch mal in Erinnerung rufen
heute finden nahezu drei Viertel aller
Güter Transporte in Deutschland auf der
Straße statt
glaubt man die Prognosen wird von diesem
Anteil auch weiterhin
vieles bleiben aber halt auf wesentlich
kürzeren Entfernungen Entfernungen unter
300 km
und die Lkw-Maut bleibt damit das
wichtigste Instrument zur Finanzierung
der
Verkehrsinfrastruktur und unsere
Mobilität
nun zunächst ein paar Worte zu ihren
Anträgen Liebe
Opposition die man nur ablehnen kann
sehr spontan wurde hier von ihnen gerade
auch noch mal gefordert von der Union
hilfs Transporte zum Wiederaufbau nach
Katastrophen von der Maut zu befreien
das klingt erst einmal auf den ersten
Blick sehr sympathisch und liegt gut im
Schaufenster aber warum bringen sie dann
nicht diesen Antrag schon in den
Vorbereitungen im Ausschuss sein sondern
erst jetzt bei dieser Debatte ich
vermute
ernsthaft beraten und rechtlich prüfen
wollen sie das nämlich gar nicht denn
sie bringen diesen Anspruch Antrag für
den Hintergrund
kurzer Toreschluss einer Rechtsprechung
die dies als sehr umstrittene
Entscheidung bisher gesehen hat ich bin
ja gerne offen für einen solchen
Vorschlag aber da müssen wir zunächst
einmal Klarheit schaffen was sagt der
Bundesfinanzhof dazu der bis jeder
solche Dinge abgelehnt hat liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen also nehmen wir
gerne auch Ihren Antrag als Anregung mit
für eine seriöse politische Prüfung
dieses Anliegens
sie haben ihn hier also meiner Meinung
nach ganz klar
unprofessionell und zu spät eingebracht
das hat mit Schulnoten nichts zu tun das
ist eine Bewertung entweder es geht
recht nicht so es geht nicht und es ist
rechtlich umstritten nehmen sie es zur
Kenntnis auch wenn sie sich hören wollen
über Herr Kollege
und dann machen sie den Vorschlag
Mauteinnahmen für das Jahr 2023
massiv zu senken fordern aber
gleichzeitig in den zurückliegenden
Haushaltsberatungen an vielen Stellen
mehr Geld da müssen sie mir mal erklären
von der Opposition wie das
Zusammenpassen soll zum einen massiv auf
Geld verzichten und zum anderen aber
massiv weitere Dinge hier im Haushalt
fordern weil wir wollen sehen mit der
Brückensanierung umgehen Sie wissen was
dazu leisten ist dafür wird Geld
gebraucht da fließt auch Geld aus diesem
Topf rein und ich denke auch das sollte
man deutlich den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
sagen das ist meiner Meinung nach eine
klare und seriöse Oppositionelle Politik
die Sie uns hier verkaufen wollen
auch dazu kann ich nur sagen
hätten sie das alles wirklich seriös
gewollt dann hätten sie es uns schon in
den letzten Wochen in den Ausschüssen
vorgelegt das haben sie nicht
sondern so ein kleiner
Entschließungsantrag in Plenum sieht für
das breite Publikum schon nach Handeln
aus ist aber nichts anderes als eine
verkehrspolitische Luftnummer die sie
hier vorführen bei dieser Debatte meine
Damen und Herren Opposition
im übrigen auch das muss man mal
erklären die Lkw-Maut wird bis
zu 50% bald von nicht deutschen
Unternehmen bezahlt also wenn Sie hier
immer betonen wir wollen deutsche
Unternehmen stärken dann stärken sie
auch die Barbara oder die Amazon
Fahrer und Spediteure dieser Welt die
hier in Deutschland viel Geld verdienen
die wollen auch Sie entlasten das ist
nicht die Politik der Sozialdemokratie
und dieser Koalition in diesem Haus auch
das sollten sie mal zur Kenntnis nehmen
und nun zum eigentlichen Gesetzentwurf
wir brauchen die Maut wir wollen
Emissionen verhindern Verkehre besser
lenken und Infrastruktur stabil
finanzieren die Maut ist dazu dass
geeignetste Steuerungssystem die
eurovignettenrichtlinie ermöglicht uns
Maut Systeme auch auf kleinere
Fahrzeugklassen in gewerblichen
Güterverkehr auszuweiten und fordert
zugleich dass dies mit einer
co2-komponente geschieht
wir sprechen heute und mit dem was im
kommenden Jahr folgt den EU-Vorgaben und
dem letzten Wege kostengutachten die
Lkw-Maut muss sich an den tatsächlichen
Kosten der Verkehrswege orientieren und
die Kosten für Luftverschmutzung und
Lärmbelastung abbilden auch das möchte
ich hier noch mal betonen mit den neuen
Sätzen wird jetzt ein zusätzlicher
Anreiz geschaffen möglichst
emissionsarme Nutzfahrzeuge einzusetzen
als nächste Maßnahme kommt dann die
co2-differenzierung und wir werden die
kleinere Nutzfahrzeuge ab 3,5 Tonnen in
die Mautpflicht aufnehmen diese Schritte
werden 2023 abschließend beraten und
soweit technisch möglich zum ersten
Januar 2024 wirksam werden und wir
müssen auch darüber diskutieren ob die
Fahrzeuge ab 2,5 Tonnen
auch noch mit in die Klassen genommen
werden auf jeden Fall kann sich die
Wirtschaft können sich die Unternehmen
weiterhin in dem Bereich auf eine
planbare verlässliche Politik dieser
Koalition verlassen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
der Vorsitzende des Verkehrsausschusses
in dieser Debatte in der es um die
Änderung geht an der Lkw-Maut Erhebung
das ganze auf der Basis einer
EU-Richtlinie die Grundlage können jetzt
auch sein Luftverschmutzung und
Lärmbelastung sie haben es teilweise in
den Reden schon gehört abendpult ist der
Brandes aus der afd-fraktion der Ampel
ist denn die Ampel betreibt die dümmste
Energiepolitik der Welt das ist
hinreichend attestiert deutsche
Transportunternehmen und Bürger kämpfen
mit gigantischen Preissprüngen und einer
unsicheren Versorgungslage mit AdBlue
sie sollten die Chance als
Bundesregierung nutzen und für nicht für
und nicht gegen Unternehmen agieren
das neue Wege kostengutachten weiß
niedrige mautheilsätze für die meisten
Fahrzeuge auf sie könnten also
flächendeckend entlasten wenn sie es
denn wollten so wie die afds in ihrem
Antrag auch fordert mit ihrem
Gesetzespaket wollen Sie stattdessen den
Unternehmen weitere zusätzliche
Belastungen auferlegen der BGL schreibt
in seiner Stellungnahme ich erzähle
Tiere mit Ihrer Erlaubnis frau
Präsidentin die vorgesehene Mauterhöhung
konterkariert die ohnehin kaum spürbaren
Entlastungsmaßnahmen der Bundesregierung
und die Bundesregierung macht die
mittelständische Transportwirtschaft zum
Spiel bei ihrer Politik genauso ist es
in diesem Entwurf wollen sie in einem
ersten Schritt die Sätze für
Lärmbelastung und
luftverschmutzungskosten massiv erhöhen
für letztere wird es für modernste
saubere Euro 6 Fahrzeuge bis doppelt so
teuer
lärmbelastungskosten sollen bis um das
Achtfache steigen sie toppen wieder
einmal die EU-Vorgaben um das Vierfache
damit nicht genug geben ihre Planung
aber noch weiter Maut Ausdehnung auf
leichte Lkw ab 3,5 Tonnen der schiefla
sie haben jetzt eben schon ist offiziell
angekündigt mit 2,5 Tonnen mautzuschlag
für den CO2-Ausstoß und zu meinem
Bedauern liebe Kollegen von der CDU wenn
ich in Entschließungsantrag lese möchten
Sie ja im Grunde auch die Maut erhöhen
aber eben nur ein Jahr später wer also
CDU wählt bekommt auch grüne Politik nur
halt mit zeitlicher Verzögerung
und jetzt wollen Sie zusätzliche
Mauteinnahmen nicht nur für die
Straßensanierung nutzen sondern auch für
ihre klimaebionologie was bedeutet das
geht es nach unseren kaviarsozialisten
finanzierter Lkw-Fahrer mit der Maut
auch das 49 euro-ticket für den Berliner
berufsaktivisten der bedankt sich und
klebt sich freitags mit Lösungsmitteln
vor ihnen auf die Straße meine Damen und
Herren
das Spiel der Grünen armee-fraktion
spielt die AFD nicht mit wir fordern
weiterhin massive Entlastung des
Mittelstands und eins möchte ich auch
noch loswerden normalerweise Regeln
Ampeln den Verkehr und verhindern
Unfälle in der bundesdeutschen Politik
verhindert die Ampel den reibungslosen
Güterverkehr meine Damen und Herren sie
hier sind der Unfall vielen Dank
Dirk Brandes afd-fraktion die AFD hat
hier auch einen Entschließungsantrag
eingereicht es gibt zwei weitere
Entschließungsanträge und zwar aus den
Reihen der Unionsfraktion zu diesem
Thema und wir warten auf die nächsten
Redner in der Debatte die wir zur Hälfte
quasi schon hinter uns haben das sollte
jetzt eigentlich Matthias Gastel sein
beim politischer Sprecher der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und das könnte
aber da ist er auf dem Weg wollte gerade
sagen es kann auch sein dass die
Bundestags viel zu Präsidentin jetzt die
Abstimmung schließt aber sie hat noch
eine Minute
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen keine Frage
die Logistikbranche ist verunsichert
Corona gebrochene Logistikketten
Entwicklungen bei den Kraftstoffpreisen
Personalmangel und vieles mehr umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir auch in Sachen
der Weiterentwicklung der Lkw-Maut für
Klarheit sorgen und genau das tun wir
wir haben das getan mit dem
Koalitionsvertrag in dem wir festgelegt
haben dass es eine co2-differenzierung
und CO2 Aufschlag geben wird wo wir
festgehalten haben dass es die
Ausweitung auf dreieinhalb Tonnen geben
wird und wo wir auch Aussagen über die
Verwendung der Mehreinnahmen getroffen
haben und wir haben uns in der Koalition
auf eine weitere Konkretisierung dieser
Aussagen verständigt nämlich das ab 1
Januar nächsten Jahres die Anpassung an
die EU Wegekostenrichtlinie erfolgt da
geht es um die Straßenbenutzung genauer
gesagt auch um die Straßen Abnutzung und
es geht um die Luftverschmutzung sowie
um den Faktor Lärm ein Jahr später
Januar 2024 kommt dann der zweite
Schritt mit einer co2-differenzierung
und den CO2 Aufschlag der Ausweitung auf
die dreieinhalb Tonnen und wir haben uns
darauf verständigt dass die
Mehreinnahmen auch den Verkehrsträgern
Schiene und Wasserwege zugute kommt und
das ist besonders wichtig das ist
besonders Schienenwege sind seit
Jahrzehnten deutlich unterfinanziert und
damit werden wir entsprechend Schluss
machen und es wäre ja wirklich absurd
dass Mehreinnahmen die aus der
Umweltbelastung resultieren in noch mehr
Straßenbau fließen um dann diese
Probleme aus denen die Einnahmen
gewonnen werden noch größer zu machen
als sie es schon sind wir sind noch eine
Koalition die Probleme lösen und kleiner
machen wollen und nicht noch größer
machen wollen
wir schaffen also wichtige Impulse im
Bereich LKW und im Bereich Logistik
dafür dass man die antriebswende
voranbringt auf alternative Antriebe
umstellt aber auch Güterverkehre so gut
es geht auf die Schiene entsprechend
verlagert das ist wichtig für das
Erreichen von Klimazielen im
Verkehrssektor denn dahin können wir
gewaltig hinterher und deswegen besteht
gerade im Bereich Güterverkehr enorme
Handlungsbedarf und Klimaziele erreichen
zu können
unser Wunsch ist dass wir dieses
Vorhaben weiter konkretisieren und zwar
möglichst schnell nicht erst Ende 2023
sondern in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten damit die Logistikbranche noch
genauer weiß was auf sie zukommt damit
sie Planungs- und Investitionssicherheit
hat und wenn wir das dann alles geklärt
haben dann gibt es immer noch einen
weiteren Handlungsbedarf ich schaue hier
beispielsweise auf die
Arbeitsbedingungen im lkw-gewerbe ich
war mit Kolleginnen in meiner Fraktion
vorletzte Woche an einer
Autobahnraststätte und habe dort mit LKW
fahrenden gesprochen aus Osteuropa um
deren Arbeitsbedingungen zu ergründen
als nochmal deutlich geworden dass wir
auch hier für Fairness sorgen müssen für
faire Arbeit aber auch für fairen
Wettbewerb gegenüber der Schiene das ist
uns als grüne ebenso wichtig wie die
Reform der Lkw-Maut
und völlig klar ist bei all dem was wir
jetzt in Sachen Lkw-Maut und
verlagerungsnotwendigkeiten auf die
Schiene diskutieren der LKW hat in der
Logistik in Marktanteil von 74 Prozent
das kann man nicht wegdiskutieren wir
werden da auch nicht auf Null kommen der
Lkw wird auch in Zukunft seine
Berechtigung haben aber er darf eben
nicht mehr die Schäden verursachen die
er heute verursacht und genau das werden
wir angehen genau dafür haben wir jetzt
den Weg entsprechend aufgezeigt mit der
mautreform in zwei Schritten schaffen
wir für die Logistik Klarheit für
zukunftige Investitionen und für
entsprechende Konzepte wie Logistik zu
organisieren ist und wir schaffen klare
Impulse für das Erreichen von
Klimaschutz auch im Güterverkehr dort
ist es sehr schwierig aber dort muss man
es eben auch umso energischer angehen
damit wir Klimaziele im Verkehrsbereich
erreichen können
Matthias Gastl für die Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen und ihm wird jetzt Thomas
Lutze Folgen Sprecher für
Verkehrspolitik in der Linksfraktion und
schon der vorletzte Redner in dieser
Aussprache
[Musik]
das Ergebnis
so und auch das haben Sie möglicherweise
halb zumindest mitbekommen in irgendwas
stimmt mit dem Mikrofon der Bundestag
viel zu Präsidentin heute nicht der sehr
viel Raum Hall mit drin das muss andere
Gründe haben als einfach nur das Mikro
an sich aber sie hat die Abstimmung zum
Energie sicherungsgesetz bzw den
Änderungen daran jetzt geschlossen es
wird gleich ausgezählt und in 10 bis 15
Minuten werden wir wieder das Ergebnis
haben kein Zweifel dass die Koalition
sich damit Mehrheit durchsetzen wird
jetzt aber endlich zu Thomas Lutze aus
der Linksfraktion
und die aufgrund der energiepreiskrise
erhebliche Schwierigkeiten hat und
obwohl ich schon ein paar Jahre hier im
Verkehrsausschuss Wirtschaftsausschuss
des Bundestags unterwegs bin hätte ich
mir nicht vorstellen können wie für
solche meist sehr kleinen Unternehmen
der Katalog doch sehr lang und sehr
schwierig ist was die alles so auf dem
Schirm haben um quasi am Markt an der
Wirtschaft teilzunehmen ihre Leute um
ihre Leute ordentlich zu bezahlen das
sage ich mal chapeau gut ab
wenn Sie jetzt die Lkw-Maut aushalten
und auch erhöhen dann denken Sie bitte
daran dass es Branchen aber vor allen
Dingen kleinere mittelständische
Unternehmen gibt für die jede
Veränderung der Rahmenbedingungen das
alles bedeuten könnte und das liegt
nicht an dieser eine spezielle Maßnahme
sonst liegt an der Vielzahl von Faktoren
die für diese die die
Faktoren
die für diese Unternehmen das
Wirtschaften möglicherweise nicht
gemacht wir brauchen und das ist richtig
streckenabgaben um die genutzte
Infrastruktur instandhalt zu halten
da gerade im Straßenbau im Straßenwesen
sind ja die Brücken besonders teuer hier
geht es schnell in die Millionen und
deswegen brauchen wir hier eine Maut und
brauchen möglicherweise auch eine höhere
Maut aber das von mir auch besuchte
Unternehmen
der Inhaber hat es abgemeldet nachdem er
über viele Monate nur rote Zahlen
geschrieben hat und einen großen Teil
seiner über Jahrzehnte angesparten
Rücklagen aufgebraucht waren denen die
noch nicht aufgegeben haben müssen Sie
sehr genau erklären warum eine Erhöhung
der Lkw-Maut unverzichtbar ist und wenn
und Sie müssen dieser Branche den
kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen viel
direkter finanziell helfen
diese Unternehmen haben kein Problem
damit LKW mal zu zahlen weil sie
abschließlich von allen Mitbewerbern
auch bezahlt wird diese Unternehmen
haben nach wie vor ganz massive Probleme
um die energiepreiskrise Zugriff zu
bekommen dazu helfen nicht dafür
brauchen einen Geld vielen Dank
Thomas Lützel der verkehrspolitische
Sprecher der Linksfraktion im
Hintergrund haben sie es vielleicht
gehört strenges Zeit Regiment heute von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Yvonne markwas
und zwar gegen alle die ampuls stehen
Henning grebach ist der letzte Redner
Unionsfraktion und war vorhin auch schon
mal angesprochen worden von Udo schief
nach dem Vorsitzenden des
Verkehrsausschusses Geld in den Erhalt
von Autobahnbrücken stecken was Sie
vergessen haben ist das was der Kollege
Gasse danach geschoben hat diese
mordserhöhung soll gar nicht in die
Autobahnbrücken gesteckt werden sondern
in andere Verkehrsträger und darüber
sind die Spediteure zu recht sauer
[Musik]
75 Jahre
speditionsverband Westfalen-Lippe da war
ich letzte Woche mit dem Kollegen schief
dazu Gast die Unternehmen haben Klartext
gesprochen die Speditionen stehen unter
großem Druck täglich kämpften mit
preissteuerung für Treibstoff für AdBlue
für Personal für Material Lieferketten
sind unterbrochen den Speditionen steht
das Wasser bis zum Hals und gerade jetzt
kommt die Ampel mit einer saftigen
Mauterhöhung um die Ecke und das auch
noch auf den letzten Drücker
es ist richtig der infrastrukturanteil
der Maut muss regelmäßig angepasst
werden das ist gesetzlich vorgegeben
aber diese zusätzliche Mauterhöhung
kommt angesichts der existenziellen
Probleme der Branche absolut zu Unzeit
und eine Erhöhung des anteiligen
mordsatzes für Lärm und
Luftverschmutzung um bis zu 700% meine
Damen und Herren das ist doch etwas
unverhältnismäßig und da geht's nicht um
Peanuts auf einer Fahrt von Hamburg nach
München und zurück sind das ab 1 23 für
1,5 LKW 40 Tonner mit vier Achsen
Mehrkosten von mehr als 300 € gegenüber
Januar 2021 für Maut und Diesel die
Grünen glauben ja je höher die Maut
desto mehr Güter gehen auf die Schiene
das Problem die Schiene ist doch
spätestens seit dem kohletransporten
voll Personenzüge müssen schon jetzt
rechts ranfahren und warten neue
Schienenstrecken werden von Grün NGOs
und Aktivisten bitter bekämpft und die
Ampel kürzt den Haushalt für die Schiene
in diesem Jahr um 775 Millionen Euro
tragen sich wenn ein grüner Minister
Habeck Terminals für fossiles
fracking-gas in wenigen Monaten
durchpeitschen kann wieso geht das nicht
beim Ausbau der Schiene
nein danke
das machen wir später
deshalb liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen bitte ich um etwas
mehr Realismus in der Debatte der Lkw
wird weiterhin die große Rolle im
Gütertransport spielen die Ampel hat er
das Ziel der Union übernommen 25%
Marktanteil des Güterverkehrs auf der
Schiene das ist richtig damit bleibt
aber weiterhin einen Marktanteil der
straßengebundenen Güterverkehrs von 65
Prozent und das darf man hier nicht
ignorieren diese Branche braucht die
volle Unterstützung auch der Ampel
in der jetzigen Lage in der jetzigen
Lage bleibt den Unternehmen gar nichts
anderes übrig als die Mauterhöhung der
Ampel eins zu eins an die Endverbraucher
weiterzugeben und das ist schon schwer
genug jeder Euro der motorhöhung der
Ampel wird von den Kunden im Supermarkt
bezahlt das sind ungefähr 540 Millionen
Euro oder umgerechnet auf jeden
Bundesbürger sind das 70 Euro vom Baby
bis zum Kreis meine Bitte an die Ampel
ziehen Sie die staatlichen
Daumenschrauben nicht noch weiter an
geben Sie den Spediteuren den
Mittelständlern und den Bürgern in
diesen schwierigen Zeiten eine Atempause
letzter Satz werden sie sich einig in
der Ampel was Sie wollen wollen sie den
LKW verteufeln oder wollen Sie die
Sorgen der Spediteure ernst nehmen
so das war in den Grillraum der letzte
Redner und das war auch glaube ich seine
letzte Chance und hätte ihm Yvonne
Marktplatz das Mikro abgestellt
oder eine persönliche Erklärung abgeben
eine Kurzintervention dann erteile ich
Ihnen das Wort dann hören wir noch mal
Udo schief nach
frau Präsidentin Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich möchte noch mal darauf
hinweisen erstens die Maut basiert in
der Umsetzung auf gesetzliche Vorgaben
und basiert auf Europa recht bevor da
ein falscher Eindruck entsteht zweitens
es ist in der Regel ein durchlaufender
Posten die die Spedition an ihre Kunden
weitergeben
drittens möchte ich feststellen dass es
unterschiedliche Haltungen dazu gibt und
ein speditionsverband sogar erklärt hat
dass er bedauert wird die baut nicht zum
ersten käme weil das bereits bei den
Kunden eingepreist wäre
also durch die verladende Industrie und
viertens ist es nicht richtig dass sie
diesem Haushaltsjahr schon bei dieser
Umsetzung die Mittel nicht auch
weitgehend die gehen in die Straße und
nicht in andere Bereiche sondern die
baut wird weiterentwickelt und wird dann
für Mobilität eingesetzt und das war
ganz deutlich zu sagen Mobilität das
Schiene Straße Wasserstraße
ab 2024
[Applaus]
ja lieber Kollege Udo schiefner vielen
Dank für diese Klarstellung das
bestätigt mich absolut in dem was ich
gerade gesagt habe die Mehreinnahmen der
Maut werden in Zukunft und das ist weit
mehr als eine halbe Milliarde Euro die
werden in Zukunft nicht in die Straße
fließen dort wo sie entstehen durch die
LKWs durch die PKWs werden sie weiterhin
nicht in die Straße gesteckt sondern der
andere Verkehrsträger und ich glaube da
muss ich die Ampel ehrlich machen und
auch das war ein Erfahrung die wir beide
gemacht haben in der letzten Woche auf
dem Podium beim speditionsverband es
gibt großen Unmut darüber dass die
Speditionen diese Maut jetzt bezahlen
müssen innerhalb von 30 Tagen wie dieses
Gesetz in Kraft treten in 30 Tagen
kriegt man das nicht weitergegeben an
seine Kunden die werden in große
Schwierigkeiten kommen und das in
Zukunft dieses Geld nicht mal für die
Autobahn verwendet wird sondern für
andere Verkehrsträger wo hier die Ampel
zurzeit das ist schon ein Uniklinik und
ich denke sie haben das gerade sehr
und deutlich gemacht vielen Dank
und damit schließe ich die Aussprache
und wir kommen zur Abstimmung über den
von der Bundesregierung eingebrachten
Gesetzentwurf zur Änderung des Bundes
Fernstraßen mautgesetzes der
Verkehrsausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussfehlung Empfehlung auf
Drucksache 44 76 den Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung auf Drucksache 31 71
anzunehmen ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen um das
Handzeichen wer stimmt dafür
dagegen Entschuldigung wer stimmt wer
stimmt dagegen
das sind cdu/csu und AFD wer stimmt ja
nein wer stimmt dafür jetzt müssen wir
jetzt zustimmen wollen erst noch mal die
Hand genau dasselbe Koalition genau ihr
stimmt zu das nee
wir enthält sich das sind die Linken ja
dann ist der Gesetzentwurf für zweite
Beratung angenommen jetzt kommen wir zur
dritten Beratung unser Schlussabstimmung
ich bitte diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen sich zu
erheben
die Ampelkoalition vielen herzlichen
Dank wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu und die afd-fraktion vielen Dank
wer enthält sich das ist die Fraktion
DIE LINKE der Gesetzentwurf ist damit
angenommen und damit können die
lkw-mautgebühren ab ersten ersten 23
steigen und anders als bisher auch mehr
an
Luftverschmutzung und Lärmbelastung des
jeweiligen Fahrzeugs orientiert werden
jetzt gibt es noch die Abstimmung zu
drei Entschließungsanträgen hier der AFD
cdu/csu und äh die Linke wer stimmt
dagegen dass die Koalition
Enthaltungen sehe ich keine damit ist
der Entschließungsantrag abgelehnt wir
kommen zum zweiten Entschließungsantrag
der Union auf Drucksache 45 83 wer
stimmt dafür
die Unionsfraktion wer stimmt dagegen
linke cdu/csu und AF ne linke Koalition
und die AFD und wer enthält sich
niemanden ist und in diesem Antrag geht
es unter anderem darum ein
entlastungsmechanismus einzuführen der
verhindert zu schreibt die Union
Fraktion das durch die zugleich
anfallenden CO2 Kosten für Kraftstoff
eine Doppelbelastung entsteht und das
sie fordert dass stattdessen die
Mehreinnahmen eins zu eins zu Entlastung
der betroffenen Unternehmen und
Verbraucher eingesetzt werden das findet
keine Mehrheit angesichts der
Mehrheitsverhältnisse hier zurück zum
Zusatzpunkt Nummer vier und mir liegt
auch schon das Ergebnis der namentlichen
Abstimmung vor über den Gesetzentwurf
Entwurf eines zweiten Gesetz zur
Änderung des
energiesicherungsgesetzes und andere
energiewirtschaftlicher Vorschriften
abgegebene Stimmkarten waren 679 mit
Jahr haben gestimmt
383 mit Nein haben gestimmt
Enthaltungen gab es 32 der Gesetzentwurf
ist damit angenommen
dann kommen wir zurück zur
Beschlussempfehlung des Ausschusses für
Klimaschutz und Energie auf Drucksache
65 45 61 der Ausschuss empfiehlt unter B
seiner Beschlussempfehlung ein eine
Entschließung anzunehmen wer stellt für
diese Beschlussempfehlung
Koalition und die Linke wer stimmt
dagegen
cdu/csu und die AFD die
Beschlussempfehlung Enthaltungen sich
keine die Beschlussempfehlung ist damit
angenommen
und schließlich kommen wir zur
Abstimmung zum Entschließungsantrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
45/84
wer stimmt dafür das ist cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen
der Rest des Hauses wer enthält sich
niemand dann ist der
Entschließungsantrag damit abgelehnt